hello everyone
um I'm super Fundy um thank you for
joining me
um I'm giving the talk a machine
language translation or the Poetry to
Shakespeare in English
um
so here is overview uh first of all I go
over my motivation for this project a
little bit about the order of poetry
Shakespeare in English the data that I
have used to train the models the
methods used
um and then we'll see the demo
um
so yeah starting off
um I would say that right now English is
kind of a dominant language of the
internet
um but not every country or state or all
people speak English natively
um so this kind of gives an opportunity
um to explore other languages
um there's around 7 100 different
languages and you can imagine the amount
of art poetry and literature that is
there to explore in these different
languages
um on its own India has 22 official
languages and one of them is ordo
so this is what weather looks like it's
certain left to right has Arabic script
uh spoken mainly in the Indian
subcontinent area
and for the love of my life
um I could just never
um get a good grade in high school in
this class but it seems like the love
for the Poetry gonna stay with me so
um this is a couplet or an Urdu called a
share by Marissa God they were very
popular
um
um for you and this is a translation
done by Mr Birch and you can see so some
of the couple of ten thousand desires
each which one were at the time for so
many fulfilled and yet still I yearn for
more
um one of the things though is the with
poetry there's a nuance and there's
um there's a cultural relatedness that
um might not come across in the
translation
um so I was with a friend of mine who
was interested or really into
Shakespearean
um Shakespeare plays um so
um I kind of conceived the idea and we
were like can we actually convert
um and translate Urdu poetry to
Shakespeare in English because it would
be really interesting to see how the
output looks like but also
um how would it be received by someone
who's into reading Shakespearean English
or Shakespearean plays
so uh this was kind of like a very
ambitious humongous task and I would
like to point out that these two are not
translations
um but basically it just kind of um
shows how ambitious our task was
um and one of the problems that we faced
is that
um Urdu is a low resource language this
is true for many
um
um non-english languages there's not
many
um not much data out there to train the
models for many of the NLP tasks so the
idea was that we'll take a high resource
language like Modern English convert or
do the Modern English and then convert
Modern English to Shakespearean English
so now we had two models
um one um Modern English another one
Modern English too Shakespeare in
English
um so we require data to train both of
these models um what we did was called
like fine tuning so we picked some of
the pre-trained models and this was the
data that we chose um we have 16 000
lines from 17 Shakespeare place um this
is what model 2 was trained on and there
is English to Urdu parallel Corpus
um this is basically Bible and Urdu
um and they're translated from Urdu to
English and then these are around 14 371
sentence pairs so um we scrape them from
the websites we aligned these and um
then we started our fine tuning um a
sample is of the original text this is a
Shakespeare play 12th night
um and then there is Apollo parlo um
translation of it modern translation of
it
so for the training we basically used
sequence to sequence Transformers
because translation is basically an
encoder decoder problem so we're going
to encode in one language we want to
decode it in the other one
um so Helsinki has a lot of models in
many different languages that are
translating from um
some non-english language to English and
then there is Shakespeare gp2 model
which is basically
um a text generation model
um and essentially for style transfer
um I'll go moreover when we get to the
slide but basically these were the two
models that I kind of used to um train a
fine tune these were regions so I
fine-tuned them using the data that um I
just showed on the previous slide so
this is an output of the Helsinki before
we even train it
um as you can see it performs pretty
well
um and on this particular data set it
had um I think a Blu score of 23.2
um and this is our candidate which is um
what the model kind of produced for this
um Source language and the reference is
the actual
um translation that we had on hand
now if you look at gpd2 which is a
causal language model it takes a
sentence and then it adds to it because
gpd2 on its own is trained on
Shakespearean employees you can see that
it adds characters in there so um when
we fine-tuned it we did not see that
Alcove because we did not have a name of
characters in there so that was kind of
handled this is not what we were
Desiring and um yeah so we were able to
handle that
um
yeah so I have a demo in place
let's see
um I had a demo in place but I'm not
able to share my screen for the Safari
browser
Gail do you think um it is something
I can be helpful you can help me with
uh yes unfortunately it uh this doesn't
work in Safari it only works in Chrome
and Firefox
okay
um
let me see if I can upload this in my
I think I have time so I'm gonna try and
upload it on my
Chrome
thank you everyone while
um Sidra uh gets things downloaded we
should be on in just a moment
so this is my working file
um this is the Marion model which was
um which basically we train and then you
have the tokenizer so um you tokenize
the text and then you um the Urdu text
gets tokenized into the model this is
the fine-tuned model that I had
um and after tokenization
see
so these are different samples of or the
Poetry guzzle that I was I was playing
around with so bezel is going to be six
couplets
um I think I um gave a sample of
I think I gave a sample of two
of one already and um
we'll just read for it to run so
basically what it does is after you have
encoded it then you want to extract the
decoder text so then you apply the
decode method
um to get the Modern English poetry
um we can right now see what I have
um already so
um as you can see in order these gets
these get perfectly translated and um
these are not these are non-poetry some
of them around here are poetry so you
can see that some of them do not get
perfectly and it'd be very interesting
to see how
um Shakespearean model basically the gp2
model kind of deals with it so
um this is the gp2 model and again we
tokenize the English text and it does
the stat transfer and you can see that
the pipeline is of text generation
and this is just the output which shows
the padding in the document and to train
the model we had used this special token
to separate
um the
the English text from The Shakespearean
tracks so you can see that in the output
and for example if you look at this
sentence which is in Modern English it
kind of returns this and then it has
multiple
um candidates
so for example keeping your mind and it
has pretty interesting output
um for that in Shakespearean English
um let's try an actual
guzzle
oops I have to load the model again
foreign
so as we can see this is the translation
um I would like to point out that it's
not necessary like the output that we
saw from this model we had certain
issues and I will be I'll dive into the
limitations and what are the
possibilities with this particular
um project but if you compare these two
um translations you would see that there
are not exactly perfect we do have a Bou
score of 13
um which is better than some data sets
but it's not as good as say 23.2 that
was observed in one of the data sets
um
so here is the generated Shakespeare in
English
um so for example as a likeness of
molten copper you have as the spirit of
the gold uh reads mine and mine so you
see that it has a certain artistic
nature to it but we can still um there's
like lots of scope of improvement
um so let me dive into the limitations
and
in the sense like what is
um
I'm just trying to re-share my slides
yep
so the limitations with this data set is
that I had computational limits um there
are much more fancier models like
embark50 birds that we could use and
um I had memory issues that was
um I couldn't work around those
constraints at that time
um there is lack of data what I saw
framing is that there is no direct
translation of Urdu poetry to
Shakespearean
um English or even Urdu poetry to
actually
um Modern English
um and
one of the biggest reasons for that is
trans translation translator
deterioration
um as you can see that is basically
writing Urdu and English text so um
this this input can be taken by an Urdu
tokenizer so but this there's a lot of
poetry out there that looks like this
um but there is definitely a dirt of
parallel Corpus um of Urdu to Modern
English especially when it comes to more
sophisticated things like
um poetry and certain kind of prose
um also or the Poetry is different than
Roman Urdu so what we see with the
um with the Helsinki model is that it's
trained on Roman Urdu
um to Modern English
um but Urdu poetry has a style to it so
it's almost like a style transfer and
kind of generative like English to
Shakespearean englishes
um so that's again one of the challenges
um that kind of face
um
so some of the future work that I hope
um gets done because I feel like
language on its own kind of anyone who
speaks another language would agree that
it opens door to the culture so there's
so much out there to explore and um
there's so much need
um for languages to be represented in
the NLP domain in the on the internet
um so I hope that this work can um you
know it can be easily extended to other
languages there's lots of Helsinki
models which work with many different
languages so it's a very replicable
project
um second there's lots of scope of
improvement
um it what it requires is is data and if
there's computational resources and data
both of those things kind of really
improve the output of this
um of the like the English Experian
English
um and
um I hope I hope that
um you know it's it gets replicated in
some ways
um this is my
um LinkedIn information if someone wants
to connect
um I also have this model like the
training models that I have they are up
um on my GitHub so I will share the link
to it
um I have my pre-trained models in our
Google Drive so
um feel free to use them download them
and if anyone has questions or wants to
collaborate with me because I am
continuing to work to improve this model
I'll be happy to hear from you
thank you
thank you very much uh we are we can
take questions now
there was a question how do you plan on
extending to other languages
um so as I said that there's lots of
Helsinki models that can be used
um also Embark can be used because they
have been trained on many different
languages one of the main constraints
that comes is data with any of the low
resource languages there's not much data
out there that we can use to stream the
NLP model so I would say from and it
sounds like it's even true for me I
speak at least two three different
languages and I would love to see them
represented what it means that
um there has to be work done to kind of
create that parallel Corpus I have been
attempting to do that but as I said um
there is certain issues that I'm running
into like transliteration
um but hopefully
um
um I I want to resolve that and um
basically um enrich the data and
basically create a data set
um
fairly Corpus I would say
I would say perfect
would you like to share any other
questions
sure I've seen the comment that
somebody's saying that they would love
to collaborate I would love to I would
love to be able like I'm always
available
um I would love to share my work and
um you know if somebody wants to create
in a different language or in the same
language
um I can definitely help out I have code
that I use for training that I think is
is definitely definitely replicable
awesome
all right
um there seems to be no more questions
and we would like uh to thank you very
much for your time and hope to see you
again uh in the next conferences
take care thank you so much